hello and welcome to my talk about
approximately strategy proof tournament
rules in the probabilistic setting
this is joint work with matt weinberg
since the title of this project is very
long let's break it down first by
talking about tournaments
let's suppose we're in the final round
of a swiss system chess tournament
there are exactly three players who have
won all their previous rounds so they're
in the running for first place
two of them let's call them a and b are
matched against each other in the last
round and the third
let's call her kimberly is going to win
her game
now a and b are staying next to kimberly
and her opponent so they observe
that she's going to win and they also
know that they're going to tie their
game
which means that both of them will get a
half point that's no good
since then they'll end the tournament
with five and a half points whereas
kimberly will have six so she'll get
uncontested first place
so a and b who happen to go to the same
school which means that they kind of
know each other
talk to each other and arrange it so
that one of them wins the game in other
words
they collude maybe a resigns even though
the position is totally drawn
then at least b has a non-zero chance of
winning the tournament on tiebreak
that's totally dishonest by the way but
whose fault is it that things turn out
this way
is it the fault of a and b or is it the
fault of the system tournament
which set up this final round matching
incentivizing a and b to perform
dishonestly
the reason why we study tournaments and
tournament rules is to see if we can
address some of these questions
and possibly design a rule that
minimizes the effect of collusion
the tournaments that we study are a
little simpler than the chess tournament
that i just mentioned
to begin with there are no ties only
wins and losses
we also assume that the tournaments are
round robin so everyone plays everyone
else
so an n player tournament can be
represented by a complete directed graph
with n vertices
each vertex represents a player and an
edge points from player i to player j if
i beats j
a tournament rule takes in this graph
and outputs a winner for most rules the
winner is not deterministic
the rule chooses some player with a
certain probability this is pretty
typical
for example any rule that breaks ties
randomly is random
in some way an exception occurs when a
rule is conversa consistent and there
exists a condorcet winner
which is a player who beats every other
player in that case a condorcet
consistent rule always declares
that player to be the tournament winner
in this simple four person tournament a
condorcet consistent rule
a would be declared the winner because
they beat everyone else
this seems pretty obvious
say though that d beats a instead
suddenly it's not as straightforward to
determine who wins
a and d are tied for first place with
two wins each so you might assume the
winner should be one of them
but maybe since d beat a d should win
but since d lost to b
who only has one point maybe a should
win or maybe we should randomly choose
between
a and d but how do we weight the choice
do we give them each one half
probability of being declared the winner
is that fair plus you might even be able
to make some sort of argument for why
b or c should win i mean it would be
kind of hard but i guess you could
do it or try in larger tournaments with
more players
the question becomes even more
complicated there are many ways to
declare winners
which role is best well maybe you want
to choose a role that minimizes
the effect of tournament manipulation in
other words you want to disincentivize
cheating
so that is what we will be examining
suppose a coalition of two players wants
to manipulate a tournament such that
collectively they have a greater chance
of winning
we'll call this group of players s they
are able to change the tournament from
what it might be originally
t to an s adjacent tournament t prime by
changing the result of the match that
they play
so maybe one player throws a match to
another this is manipulation
we call a tournament rule two strongly
non-emitted fieldable
or two s m if a group of two players
can't increase their collective
probability of winning
at all as it turns out you can't have a
rule that's both condorcet consistent
and strongly non-manipulable
and we'll see an example of why shortly
so
we are forced to compromise we prefer to
keep conversate consistence
over a strong non-manipulability since
it seems natural that someone who beats
everyone else should win the tournament
we define a role as two s m alpha if a
group of two players can't increase
their collective probability of winning
by more than alpha
previous work has shown that one-third
is the lower bound on alpha
consider this triangle tournament where
everyone beats exactly one other player
in a cycle like this
it's not automatically clear who should
win but any tournament rule must assign
probabilities of winning to a b and c
and these probabilities must sum to one
there has to be a winner
assuming we have a condor say a
consistent rule r then there exists some
player
without loss of generality let's say c
who wins with probability at least one
third
under this role in this cycle so a and b
have almost two thirds chance of winning
under r
but if a and b collude and a loses to b
on purpose
then b wins with probability one because
r is conjure say consistent
so you see that arrow flips and b is now
pointing to a because b beats a
so a and b have increased their
collective chances of winning by at
least one-third
that's why alpha is lower bounded at
one-third and that's a simple example
of manipulation
however what if a and b want to collude
but they don't know the outcome of each
match
and what if the outcome of each match is
uniformly at random that is
everyone beats everyone else with
probability one half
and let's assume for now that if a cycle
occurs for example if a beats b
and b beats c and c beats a then the
rule we're using declares the winner
uniformly at random
so in this case a and b don't gain
anything by throwing their match one way
or another
since between the two of them each is
equally likely to be a condorcet winner
and each is equally likely to be a cycle
winner so
okay um so we've concluded that if
matches are uniformly random like this
then collusion doesn't really help
but what if matches are almost uniformly
at random
after all in most tournaments the
colluding players do not know the
outcome of every other match before they
decide how to collude
that's really a best case scenario for
including players so it's a worst case
scenario
for the world designer who wants to
minimize collusion
so let's take the other end of the
extreme and consider a tournament where
no one knows the outcome of any of the
matches to draw a real world analogy
this is like
examining the list of players before the
start of the first round
you have some idea of who's going to
beat who but of course you're not sure
and let's assume that for some reason
including pair of players has to decide
how they're going to collude right now
before they see the outcome of any
matches of course most real world
situations are probably going to fall
somewhere in the middle
um the colluding players are going to
know the outcome of some matches but not
others
when they decide how they're going to
throw their match but that is
a question for a different project
we define an n player probabilistic
tournament as a distribution
over the set of all n player tournaments
an easier way to think about it is a
probability on the direction of each
directed edge in the n vertex graph that
represents the tournament
i've included a diagram for convenience
um and you see in this diagram
a beats b with probability one-half plus
epsilon
so it's not illustrated but what you can
include is that b beats a with
probability one-half minus epsilon
so a probabilistic tournament is
independent if all matches are
independent
of each other and it's weakly epsilon
bounded if probabilities are
drawn from the range one-half minus
epsilon one-half plus epsilon
of course epsilon is at most one-half we
want to know if we can construct
tournament rules that have a certain
probability of working here
our main result consists of two rules
that are two s
m one-third epsilon plus two-thirds
epsilon squared which is at most
one-third
and in fact this bound is tight
also in the paper we develop a useful
way to analyze recursive tournament
rules when applied to probabilistic
tournaments
in fact this analysis also works in the
deterministic setting since that's just
a version of a probabilistic tournament
where epsilon is one half
one of the two rules we examine is a new
rule called randomized deathmatch
which is a tournament where every round
only two randomly selected players
participate in a match against each
other
and the loser gets eliminated the other
is randomized single elimination bracket
which has
previously been studied rcb randomly
seeds a single elimination bracket with
the tournament players
padding the original set of players with
a set of dummy players to reach a power
of two if necessary
the dummy player is always loose so
there's the equivalent of taking a bye
playing one is equal to taking a bite
it's just a little easier to think about
so this may not seem recursive at first
but consider the fact that randomly
saving a bracket with initial padding
is equivalent to randomly selecting
perfect matching with initial padding
every round given that you win your
first round in a single elimination
tournament
you are equally likely to play any other
first round winner in round two
a third recursive tournament role is
randomized king of the hill which has
also previously been studied
under this rule every round a randomly
selected prince has to play everyone
else
and everyone who loses the game gets
eliminated including the prince if they
don't win all their games
but first let's talk about the proof
framework let's talk about the collision
itself and call the colluding players u
and v
uh which we will call them from now on
at the start of the tournament there is
of course a non-zero chance that you and
v are able to collude somehow
usually of course you and v can only
collude when they play each other since
that's the only match where they can
control the outcome
if they never play each other they can't
collude so their probability gain is
zero
so every round something happens um
maybe we have a recursive event
which means you and v don't play each
other but they both remain in the
tournament
so no collusion has occurred yet but
collusion might still occur
and we recurse usually to a smaller
tournament because other players have
been eliminated
alternatively if you and v do play each
other
then one of them is eliminated and they
can't ever collude again after
that round so we call this a terminal
event
um because it terminates the possibility
of collusion in the future
but this is a bad terminal event since u
and v did have the opportunity to
collude
so from the perspective of the rule
designer it would be ideal if this never
happened
if you or v are eliminated by someone
else then they also can't ever collude
so this is also a terminal event but
it's a good one which the rule designer
prefers
another type of good terminal event
occurs if u and b
become identically distributed then
their collusion doesn't matter
what exactly does this mean
the simplest example is when you and v
are the last two players remaining in
the tournament
it doesn't matter then who throws the
match to who because obviously one of
them is going to win
so the probability gained from collusion
is zero
another example is when they are not the
last two players
but they both beat all remaining players
with identical probabilities
once again if they ever play a match it
doesn't matter who wins or loses
they're not going to gain anything from
during the match one way or the other
and i've included some illustrations for
your convenience
we would like to bound the worst case
scenario that you and v
meet and play match and that they are
able to increase their collective chance
of winning
the total expected probability gain from
their collusion is the expected gain
from the terminal events
added to the expected gain from
recursing to a smaller tournament after
recursive
there's an inductive proof in the paper
and the main takeaway is that
we get this expression that upper bounds
the maximum probability gain that u and
v can achieve
given that we are able to find these
three values um
c b and g so we upper bound the gains
from that terminal event
uh we upper bound the probability of a
bad terminal event occurring
and we lower bound the probability of a
good terminal event
so this is what we want to do when we
reason about worst case scenarios
because we want to upper bound the
effect of bad events and lower bound the
effect of good events
essentially
so as a warm-up we'll use the recursive
framework to reason about some
tournament rules in the deterministic
setting when epsilon is one half and all
probabilities are either zero or one
so first let's talk about this new rule
randomized deathmatch which you'll
recall consists of only two players
playing a match every round with the
loser getting eliminated
and i've included an illustration for
your convenience
it's clear that for this rule and in
fact for any tournament rule
the most win probability that any
coalition can gain via collusion
is one so c equals 1 is our upper bound
next we'll consider the probability of a
bad terminal event which occurs only
when u and v
play if the tournament has n players
then their n choose 2 equally likely
matches
each round and the bad one is only one
of them so this gives us b
equals 1 over n choose 2.
next we'll try to lower bound the
probability of a good terminal event
the general idea is that the only teams
that are important to us are the ones
that treat you and b differently
suppose all teams either beat both u and
v or lose to both u and v
then u and v would be identically
distributed and collusion would have no
impact
so we define l u to be the number of
teams who beat u and not v
and lv to be the number of teams who
beat v and not u
without loss of generality assume that l
u is at least as great as lb and i just
realized that i've been saying
teams here um were used teams and
players interchangeably
in the play uh in the paper as well
as we just saw if lu and lv are both
zero then there's no possibility of
collusion so technically the probability
of a good terminal event is one
if l u and lb sum to two or more then
the probability that either you or v
plays someone who beats them is at least
two over n choose two
finally if l u is one and lv is zero
uh then we have exactly one team call it
w that beats u but not v
there are still two matches that could
be good terminal events either w plays u
then eliminates z which is good
or v plays w and eliminates w which
means that u and v are now identically
distributed
so these probabilities sum to two over n
choose two
so in all situations the probability of
a good terminal event is at least
two over n choose two which means we can
say that g equals two over n choose two
and then given our values for c b and g
we conclude that the maximum gain from
collusion is at most one-third
let's repeat the exercise with the
previously studied rule randomized
single elimination bracket
we note that once again c equals one um
and b the probability that u
or v play a match is one over n prime
minus one where
n prime is the number of players after
padding the tournament with dummy
players
recall that we do this so that the
structure of the single elimination
bracket is neat
and i've once again included an
illustration for your convenience
and again the calculations for g are a
little more complicated
we define l u and l v as we did before
and point out that if they're both zero
we are already in a good terminal case
if l u is two or more then u is
eliminated with probability
two over n prime minus one so
that's already good we don't have to
worry about the rest
if l u is one um and lv is zero then the
same thing occurs
either let w be the unique team uh that
beats u
but not v and then either u plays w and
loses or v plays w and wins
uh and these are both good terminal
events again so the probability is two
over
n prime minus one and then finally let
uh lu equal one and lv
equal one uh and then let w be the
unique team that beats u but not v
and let x be the unique team that beats
v but not u
so a good terminal event would consist
of you playing w
or v playing x but these events are not
mutually exclusive
so they actually um don't sum to two
over and
prime minus one as we want but we then
note that another good terminal event
consists of
you playing x and v playing w since then
both w and x will be eliminated in the
same round and u and v will become
identical
so added together these probabilities
are two over n prime minus one
and the full calculations are in the
paper so
now we have g equals two over n prime
minus one which works out nicely and
shows that the maximum gain
under rcb is at most one-third which is
true and has been proven before
separately using a separate method which
is very good news
so now we move from the warm up to the
general case where epsilon can be
anything
in our warm up we set c equals one which
was trivial
but now we do not have that luxury and
we would like a tighter bound
we note that if you and v were to play
then regardless of who wins the match
the winner must beat the same group of
other players in order to win the
tournament
we call this group the gauntlet for
example in a single elimination bracket
the gauntlet consists of all the winners
of the other relevant matches
which are determined independently of
the winner of the uv match
you can imagine that maybe all these
matches have already been resolved
um while the uv match is still going so
everyone's just waiting for you and b to
finish up and they'll
all play the winner in time incidentally
this is where the proof fails for
randomized king of the hill
you'll recall that in randomized king of
the hill one player is selected as
prince each round
in that case the gauntlet might change
depending on who is prince since you and
v might beat different players with
different probabilities
anyway the existence of the gauntlet
means that the difference in wind
probabilities is at most two epsilon
because it's difference between one half
plus epsilon to some
power minus one-half minus epsilon to
the same integer power
there's an additional factor of one-half
plus epsilon because in an ordinary
tournament without collusion
there's at least one-half minus epsilon
chance that the result of the uv match
turns out the same way as a result
under collusion so we have to subtract
that
finding b the upper bound probability of
a bad terminal event
is a little more straightforward in fact
it's identical to our calculations in
the warm up
the event itself doesn't actually change
finding
g is more complicated and the full
calculations are in the paper
but you'll see that it does end up the
same as a warm-up
the results anyway so these are what
they are
and then using our framework we can
conclude that the maximum gain from
collusion
caps out at 1 3 epsilon plus 2 3 epsilon
squared for both rules
um so next we want to know this bound
tight and
the answer is yeah it is um well let's
get into that
so let's look at this triangle
tournament again so this is familiar but
now it's a probabilistic triangle
tournament everyone beats the person in
front of them with probability one-half
plus epsilon
so let r be any condorcet consistent
tournament rule we don't know much about
r but we know that whenever a cycle
occurs
r must assign win probabilities to each
of the three players
there are two such cycles which i've
named cycle one and cycle two
with second one being the more likely
cycle let's call the wind probabilities
in cycle one
alpha a alpha b alpha c and
the others beta a beta b beta c
we note that in a regular tournament
everyone's overall win probabilities
look similar
there's a probability that there's that
that player is a condorcet winner
and then there's a probability that
either cycle occurs multiplied by their
win probability for that cycle
so the only differences are in the
values of alpha beta et cetera they
might be different
now let's look at this version where a
deliberately loses to b
so they're colluding again now this
increases the chance
of being condorcet winner it also
increases the probability of cycle two
and it means that cycle one can actually
never occur
so we note that the overall probability
gain is expression
um well it exists but it still has alpha
and beta in it
um but we do note that there are three
possible coalitions here
so since the other two coalitions have
similar probability gains
um by the other two i mean b and c and a
and c
who do like their respective uh game
throwing
actions um you can just replace the beta
and alpha terms
in the a b probability gain expression
to get the probability gain for those
coalitions um and then if we sum up
those probability gains
and divide by three we get the average
probability gained across
all coalitions and because the alpha and
beta terms sum to one
when um all three of them together we
can actually
just replace them with one so what
happens is we get this average
probability gain
uh figure with only numbers and epsilon
in it
and we get the same one-third epsilon
plus two-thirds epsilon
squared uh expression that we've always
had
so because this is the average
probability gain there must be some
collision that can achieve at least this
much probability gain
which means that no condensate
consistent tournament rule can do better
than 2 s m 1 3 epsilon plus 2 3
epsilon squared at least when the
tournament is independent
and probabilistic in this fashion
so in conclusion we found a tight lower
bound for an
upper bound of probability gain via
manipulation for counter-strike
consistent torment rules
we've also developed a useful recursive
framework to help analyze recursive
rules
future work might find a way to reason
about randomized king of the hill
which is more difficult to reason about
because we can't easily compute the
probability gain via manipulation
due to its non-matching elimination rule
as we mentioned earlier this messes up
the gauntlet
future work might also want to consider
probabilistic tournaments that are not
independent
so the matches might be correlated with
each other in some way
their outcomes the recursive framework
could be used for other problems as well
anyway that concludes the talk thank you
very much for listening and i hope you
have a good day